this idea of the introject is
fascinating to me because what it says
is that if you consume enough of that
content if you read enough books about
people who have embarked on certain
kinds of Journeys and made certain
choices that at some point you might
interject some of their personality and
their responses and subconsciously start
making decisions hopefully positive
decisions on your own behalf maybe
having more appropriate boundaries maybe
taking better self-care or care of other
people and then at some point you move
from the interject to a recognition that
wait it was me that made that change I'm
the one that managed to get up a bit
earlier and do a little bit more to be
kinder in this context or to listen a
little bit better in this context the
information that we consume sets the our
the internal context of our subconscious
and sets the internal context for what
we decide to do consciously and in many
ways it's sort of like garbage in
garbage out and if it's you know
positive stories and inspiration in
that's how you're basically going to
react in the world